for example the meat tax
there is nothing about it inverkiezingsprogramma
green left was for
but the PvdA lives against it
because we have lilian ploumen
Heard it said 2 years ago
that disproportionately affects lower incomes
and she found that people at least 4 times a week
1 meatball
had to be able to eat
so my question to you is
how about that
that means we are there
will have to have left in the future
you did not get out of there
no we didn't talk about it
sincerely not
a lot of things have landed in the program
not this
I think you
must do everything to stimulate
that people eat less meat
I think youbelastingmaatregelen especially
should reduce the tax on products that are healthy
on fruit and vegetables
so that would rather be my direction